Nancy's in New York welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show Nancy Oh Dave I'm so glad to
talk to you you too um thanks for taking
my call I'm at a crossroads in my life
and I really need your help okay I'm 65
years old I inherited $200,000 cool I do
not have enough money in my retirement
and that's kind of an understatement I
have about $50,000 in retirement
mm-hmm I have about 96,000 on my
mortgage that's two mortgages together a
primary and secondary those are variable
rates one of the three and a half here
there's at five and a half what's the
house worth okay nine hundred thousand
dollars you only own ninety-six okay
yeah you sell real estate
I do the contractor great what's your
household income it's about 150 why do
you not have any money save for
retirement
that's a good question it's a
combination of things obviously some of
it is living beyond our means some of it
is I have a chronic health condition and
we've we've spent about $25,000 a year
for health insurance and insurance
frankly workers comp liability property
insurance savings in New York you still
should have save some money
right right now I and you got a 96
thousand dollar mortgage helmet what
other kind of debt have you got I have
10 vehicles that we bought last year and
hindsight's 20/20 we shouldn't have
bought them one was a new truck for my
husband which he actually has earned
he's been driving you know secondhand
stuff all his life and we bought a
secondhand Jeep for me now so the
combined debt between the two of them is
about fifty thousand each other he did
not own the truck that's a lie okay you
earn the truck when you're the my to pay
for it all right you guys have to stop
this you're 65 years old you're broke
well that's why I'm calling yeah I know
and two hundred thousand is not gonna
help you if you don't stop a bleeding
here on this truck the truck is about
30,000 the juice is about money
yeah about 20 right exactly well
shortest distance between where you are
and wealth is debt-free
mathematically but that's not gonna help
you guys I know if you don't stop this
other stuff I'm thinking about investing
some of the 200 it's not enough you have
to get your body the body of your income
under control you are you you you are
you guys have just spent everything
you've made your whole life you
basically have to stop that now I mean
you know bought a thirty thousand dollar
truck yeah I mean maybe after that you
stopped I don't know when you stopped
but you know you guys you you that's
what scares me so if I knew you had
stopped if I knew the two of you would
never say something like you earned the
right to go into debt $30,000 that's not
that's a punishment that's not that's
not a reward you know you can't say
stuff like that anymore you can't think
that way anymore you've got to live on
less than you make and plow money back
into retirement aggressively then if I
knew that was all true I'd write a check
and pay off every debt that be the first
thing I'd do house Mars everything which
is not going to leave you at about 50
grand I know that's what I don't I don't
want to do that I don't want to
I don't want to I don't want to see it
all you already spent at all yeah you're
just admitting it when you pay off the
debt mm-hmm so either do that or sell
the truck and you're gonna have to get
yourself on a budget and the two of you
need to go through Financial Peace
University I'll pay for it I want you to
win I want you to retire with dignity if
you two will go to the class I'll give
it to you it's nine weeks long and then
you have a one-year participation in the
online but you guys it is time for some
old dogs to learn some new tricks here I
actually looked for a financial piece
class in my area and I'd like to have to
go to some part of New Jersey okay
well sign you up and you can you can do
it online or you can start a class in
your area but I'll give it to you free I
want you to go but you guys have got to
you've got to make the decision to never
again spend money you don't have and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take you to baby step 3
instantaneously with this money and then
you order to baby step 4 and then you're
gonna seven your house is paid off okay
so you're millionaires but you're broke
millionaires you've paid for nine
hundred thousand dollar house paid four
hundred thousand dollars where the
vehicles paid for everything and now
we're gonna take all of your cash flow
and build wealth with it in a nest egg
as fast and aggressively as you can and
that's what I would do and if you can
build a half million to a million
dollars in mutual funds before you to
quit working and I think you can then
you will probably be able to keep this
house if you can't then the house is
probably going because it's the only
asset you have and you've got to have
some money for food at retirement so if
you don't want to spend all of this
money the only way I can see to avoid
that is to sell the truck and somehow I
don't think you're gonna do that